[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN HOLL: This is really cool.
I get to do a lot of really cool
things in my life and my job.
This is one of those
things like where,
since I use your products
daily, almost minute by minute
in my life, being here--
one, I'm really nervous about
what you guys know about me.
But two, this is
a real privilege.
So thanks for having me.
KEVIN NELSON: Our
pleasure, John.
Thanks so much for coming.
Let's go ahead
and dive right in.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: You
open up the book
talking about your history
of discovering beer.
I believe your father
drank Heineken.
JOHN HOLL: He did.
He does.
KEVIN NELSON: And what
did the other members
of your family drink?
JOHN HOLL: They were
a lot of Bud drinkers.
a lot of Bud Light drinkers.
I think just given
the time, and I
think this is relatable
to a lot of folks
as well, our parents, our
grandparents, whatever,
drank whatever was available
to them at the time
or whatever they perceived
their brand to be.
So there were families that were
Schaefer families, or Bud Light
families, or Busch
families, or whatever.
My dad, for whatever reason--
and I still haven't
talked to him about this,
even though it's in the book--
he would get Heineken
in the house.
And he just kind of liked it.
He liked the weird
skunky taste, I guess.
And when I would sneak tastes
when I was 12 or 13 or 14,
whatever, you know--
yeah, about that--
this is terrible.
Like, why would you
want to do this?
And I drink it today, I'm
like, this is terrible.
Why would you want to do that?
But it's also-- it's
a really fine beer,
and it's a well-made beer.
So I think drinking-- so much
of what our experiences are,
depending on your
age, comes from those
who we were watching.
We were watching their habits.
I learned it from watching you.
And we're at this
point, though, where,
with so many breweries
in the country
that, my daughter, who's
20 months old right
now, by the time you know she
hits 18 in the UK and 21 here,
she'll know a world that has
endless beer possibilities.
So I have no idea what'll be
in my fridge at that point
or what she'll gravitate
towards, but yeah,
so much of it is just timing.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah.
My grandfather drank Schlitz.
He was my introduction to beer.
And when I was young,
probably starting at age
seven or eight, when I
would go to his house.
He had bought these
little eight-ounce,
barrel-shaped beers.
And he would give
me one of those.
So I've been a beer lover
since, you know, walking time.
I also enjoyed
your story about--
I think you described it as
choking down your first IPA
at the local brew pub.
What do you think about that
today when thinking back?
JOHN HOLL: You know,
so it's twofold.
And I don't want to
disparage too much.
I still go back to
that brewery where
I drank my first IPA
on draft, as it were,
on my 21st birthday.
I walked into this
local brew pub,
and I forced myself to
drink a beer because I
wanted to drink better beer.
I wanted to be accustomed
to something that was not
what everybody was drinking at
the frat parties or the college
parties.
And the bartender
served me this IPA
and laughed at me as I was
like, ugh, this is terrible.
You know, he sounded like
Cleo in the beginning.
But the cool thing is that
the bartender actually
explained hops to me.
And when we think about IPAs,
and it's the most popular craft
beer style right now, it's
bitter for the most part.
It's hop forward, and hops are
part of the cannabis family.
You can't do with hops
what you do with cannabis.
Like, don't try.
I don't know what the policy
is here, but just don't.
Hops are good for making
beer and making beer only.
But in those early
days, and even still,
it's a bittering agent
in a lot of ways.
And when you say
"bitter" to people, like,
oh, I don't want to try bitter.
But this bartender
started talking to me
about pine and grapefruit
and citrus and some
of these other
flavors and aromas
that are derived from hops.
And I think once you can
flip your brain to that
and start thinking about
it those ways as opposed
to just the bitter
sensation, but actually
what it is that we're
tasting and experiencing,
it brings you around
in a whole new way.
So I'm really grateful that I
ordered a second pint that day
and that it inadvertently set
me off to where I am right now.
Which is, again, in this,
you know, cool room.
KEVIN NELSON: I used to
travel quite a bit to England
in my 20s, so long time ago.
And remember what a revelation
it was to go to a pub
there and have a cask ale,
a pulled English bitter.
And these days,
the term "bitter"
is kind of a misnomer compared
to what we drink today
with West Coast IPAs.
But it was my
introduction to the--
I think you described it
as non-beer-tasting beer.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
And I think beer-flavored beer
is one of these things where--
and I talked about this
a little bit in the book.
But we lost our food
traditions in a lot
of ways in the same time that
we lost our beer traditions.
And so we used to know where
all of our food came from,
and we used to know
where our beer came from.
Before Prohibition, there was
something like 4,300 breweries
operating in the
country, which is crazy
when you think about it.
And back in those times, if
you were drinking local beer
in wherever city you were in,
you knew where it came from.
And you knew where your meat
came from, and your vegetables,
and your bread, and your
cheese, even if you made it
at home kind of thing.
And then we lost
our way with, like--
Velveeta became--
instead of real cheese
and fresh-baked bread,
it was Wonder Bread,
and a plastic tray in the
microwave for five minutes,
and we called it dinner.
And before
Prohibition, the beers
were stouts and saisons and
ales of all different kinds,
and spruce tip, whatever.
And then, by the time
we got out of it,
it was all beer-flavored
beer in the same way.
And so we've sort of come back
a little bit in a great way
where you can eat local and
you can drink local in ways
like you haven't before.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, interesting.
Beer, of course, has
an ancient history.
And there's even
some scholarship now
that suggests that beer is the
actual root of civilization
as opposed to bread,
which we normally hear.
I can't think of anything
better than having
people sitting in one spot--
JOHN HOLL: I like the
laughter that's happening.
Like, people are like, yeah,
those are my ancestors.
That's cool, yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: And then,
of course, for years,
drinking beer was safer
than drinking water.
JOHN HOLL: Oh, yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: So maybe give
a little history on that end
and also the role beer played in
the founding the United States.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, so
there's a lot of evidence
to suggest that the nomadic
tribes early on would find
sweet grass that they would
then steep in warm water
and it would become beer.
Or even not steep in warm water,
just, like, naturally ferment.
They'd put grass in water,
and the sugars would naturally
ferment from the
yeast in the air,
and that they would happily
get drunk off of it.
And when they found places
that they were like,
oh, we like this.
Let's stay here,
because it's good to us,
and the goddess Ninkasi,
who is the goddess of beer,
is good to us in this place.
And so a place--
people would stay there.
But when you look
back, especially
to the United States,
this is a country
that was founded on beer.
Captain Bradford's diaries
from the "Mayflower"
said, "Our victuals were running
low, especially our beer."
And so beer was potable
water on the ships.
And the original plan was
to go down to Virginia.
But they stopped off in
Massachusetts instead
and got down to the
business of brewing,
because the beer on board, this
3.2 near-beer Porter, whatever,
that was their food,
their sustenance they
were almost out of.
And then, from that
point on-- and I
talked about this in the
book a little bit more--
of during the
Revolution, you know,
the Founding Fathers
were drinking ales,
were drinking ciders.
We hear a lot about how
George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson were homebrewers.
A lot of that's nonsense.
They weren't like
sitting around the garage
with their sleeves rolled
up and fife music playing
in the background as they're
mashing in their homebrew
recipes.
No, it was done by the
women of the household
or the slaves of the
house at the time.
But they played a role in it.
And then suddenly we became
a country of immigrants.
And if you were a
barber or a baker
or a tailor in the Old
World, you'd come over
and you'd apply that here.
And we were really lucky to
have a lot of brewers who
came over as well and set up.
And so yeah, we've had a really
long, complicated relationship
with beer in this country
for a really long time.
And it continues to today.
KEVIN NELSON: Very interesting.
So beer is made traditionally
with four ingredients.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: Malted barley,
hops, water, and yeast.
And yeast was only
discovered a little later.
It kind of happened by
accident for a long time.
JOHN HOLL: Right.
We thought it was magic.
We thought it was a
gift from the gods.
KEVIN NELSON: People
would use the magic stick,
and they would--
stirring the juice, and
it would turn into beer.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: And the word
"malt" is kind of funny.
The only other place
we hear the word "malt"
is with malted milk
balls or malted milk.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: What is malt,
and how did those ingredients
come together to make beer?
JOHN HOLL: Well, malt is--
it's a grain.
And so you can use all
different kinds of grain.
You can use rye or
sorghum or rice or corn.
And a lot of brewers do
in their beer as well.
So it is basically a means
to get sugar into water.
You boil the grain
to get it into water,
and then the yeast is added--
the hops are added for
flavor and for bittering.
And then yeast comes
into the play afterwards
and eats the sugars and creates
alcohol and carbonation,
as it were.
But I think, arguably, the
most important ingredient
to talk about is water.
And without it, we
wouldn't have beer.
Without it, we
wouldn't have life.
Without it, we wouldn't have our
general existence, as it were.
And it's fascinating to me that
homebrewers and beer drinkers,
they love talking about
hops first and foremost.
It's the flavors, the
aromas, the bitterness.
It's a very sexy,
exciting ingredient.
Water is just-- we sort
of take it for granted.
We turn the tap,
and there it is.
But when you think about
how much of the world
doesn't have access
to fresh water,
or what you see happening
in Flint, Michigan,
and in some other
cities as well,
we as beer fans
and beer drinkers,
and especially as the
brewers themselves,
need to be thinking about where
their water is coming from
and how to protect the
resource to fight back
against people who are trying
to damage our water sources.
And that, to me, I think is
the most important thing that
doesn't get talked about.
But now that I just
bummed out the room,
I think we should
probably have a beer.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, so I agree.
It's fun to talk about beer, but
it's a lot more fun to drink.
So what are we going
to try here first?
JOHN HOLL: So this
is Allagash Saison.
I'm just going to do a--
KEVIN NELSON: Thank you.
JOHN HOLL: --reach
over for you there.
KEVIN NELSON: Perfect.
And talk about
tasting beer, too.
How should we approach this as
we taste our first beer today?
JOHN HOLL: All right,
so right off the bat,
and I'm not faulting you
guys, but this is actually
really kind of cool.
So on this glass, you're
going to see carbonation
sticking to the inside.
And Cleo's going to lose
her mind a little bit.
But you see the carbonation
sticking to the inside walls
of the glass?
That's probably because
this is a fresh glass,
and it hasn't been
fully rinsed out yet.
But if you walk into
a place like a bar,
and you see carbonation
sticking to the inside,
that typically
means that there's
some dust behind or
some soap residue,
or something that makes
it a non-beer-clean glass.
Again, we're all
fine here today.
And I'm actually really
glad that that happened,
because it's a pet peeve of
mine when I'm out at a bar,
especially a place that
considers themselves
to be a beer bar.
But in the same way that you'd
return a dirty fork if you
got it at a restaurant, it's
just one of those things
to be mindful of.
KEVIN NELSON: So I
want to assure you,
first of all, that we
handwashed all the glasses
and rinsed them, because
we knew this could come up.
JOHN HOLL: It's in the book.
It's one of my
things in the book.
All right, so a couple of
quick ways to taste beer.
First, also, when you're
doing Instagram or Twitter
or whatever you guys
are doing these days.
Google+--
[AUDIENCE GROANING]
Labels out always.
Sorry, sorry.
That was mean.
That was so mean of me.
So always labels out first
so that people can see
what you're doing.
Appearance is really important.
Think about what the
color makes you think of.
Is it the color
of autumn leaves?
Is it black as night?
Is it the color of a
sunset or whatever?
Think about what the
color of the beer
makes you think of in your mind.
Next thing is aroma.
And you kind of get it
going to about 45 rpm.
Older folks in the
room are like, cool.
The hipsters are like, yeah,
and everybody else is like, huh?
So you do that.
And then most people will go
like this [INHALES DEEPLY]
to smell the beer.
Don't do that.
Like, don't.
Not only are you going to
get the tip of your nose wet,
and you don't want that, but
it's not going to help you.
So the thing that I kind of
like to do is like a typewriter,
or like a drive by, where
you just start to inhale,
and you run the glass
under your nose.
So you're getting
the ambient air,
and then you're
getting the beer,
and then you're getting
the ambient air again.
And starts to think
about flavors.
And we can talk more about
that, I guess, but think
about the flavors that
are coming through,
the aromas that
are coming through.
Does it smell spicy?
Does it smell like lemon?
Does it smell like whatever?
Then the next thing
is obviously taste.
And that's the fun
part, certainly.
But so much of what we perceive
as taste comes from aroma.
And so think about
what you just smelled.
If it was a lemon or a
cake or whatever spice
that comes through.
And now is it is it
much more acute now
that you've tasted the beer?
And it probably should be.
And then the next thing
to take into consideration
is mouth feel.
And so you take a
sip and you hold it
on your tongue for about
three seconds or so.
And feel the carbonation.
Is it like Scrubbing Bubbles,
or is it a little bit more flat?
Does the liquid feel thick?
Does it feel watery?
A lot of people will say to
me, oh, I don't like Guinness.
It's much too heavy.
And they're just judging
the beer by its color.
But if you ever take
a sip of Guinness,
it's very watery on the tongue.
There's almost no body
to that particular beer.
But some of the IPAs
that we're going
to have in a minute that
are lighter in color
are going to coat
your tongue and sort
of this oily, slick kind of way.
And then the last
thing to consider
while you're tasting a beer
is really do you like it?
And if so, great,
have some more.
And if not, if you're
like Cleopatra, it's--
I'm sorry, you're just
going to be the running
foil for this entire talk now.
That's cool, because there's
7,000 breweries in the country
right now, and they're all
making a multitude of styles.
And you'll find
something that you like.
Like this saison
from Allagash, which
has been making great beer
in Maine for 25 years now,
and is one of the top
brewers in the world.
And they do
Belgian-inspired beers,
and this is a
Belgian-inspired beer.
And this is one of the
best examples in the US
that's being made today.
So that's why we got it.
KEVIN NELSON: Very nice.
Tasty.
Everyone like that one?
Who liked that one?
Who didn't like that
one, besides Cleo?
JOHN HOLL: All right,
but really quick,
what don't you care about it?
There's a guy in a
blue shirt back there.
What didn't you care about it?
AUDIENCE: I just
don't like the flavor.
I don't know how else to put it.
I mean, I like the
mouth feel, but I
don't care for the flavor.
KEVIN NELSON: So that
clove cinnamon flavor
isn't your thing?
JOHN HOLL: And
that's cool, right?
I mean, and that's the thing.
Like, this isn't an
attack by any means.
So often in beer
geek culture today,
though, people will try to
convince you why you're wrong.
And I don't think that
that's a fair thing.
And I think that
the smart brewers
know that diversity is king.
And so you can walk into
Allagash, you can get stouts.
They make their table beers.
They make a whole
bunch of other stuff
as well, because they know
that not one style of beer
is going to appeal to everybody.
And there's some brewers that
just make one style of beer,
and I think they're
alienating themselves
a little bit you know too much.
So like, yeah.
I think if you give
every beer a fair shake,
and that's what I like to talk
about in the book a little bit.
But give every beer a fair
shake, but also in the same way
that if you don't
like Brussels sprouts,
or you don't like goat cheese,
or you don't like anything
else that we experience
in life, nobody gives you
a hard time for that either.
So the beer fans
that try to give you
a hard time for
not liking a beer,
I don't think they're
doing it right.
KEVIN NELSON: Go
with what you like.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: Absolutely.
So this is one style of beer.
We have these four ingredients--
malt, hops, water, and yeast.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: How do you make
different styles of beer?
What goes into that?
JOHN HOLL: So, so much of it
is how much you use of each.
And then, again, there's
different flavor components
to each of the main ingredients.
And so I like to--
I think I might have
talked about this
the last time I was here.
But if you look at the
four main ingredients,
and you think about
them in food terms,
so water doesn't always
just tastes like water.
It can have a salinity to it, or
a little bit of an iron content
to it.
Or it can be hard
water or soft water.
But if you travel around enough,
or you grew up in a place
where you got your water
from a well versus now
you're getting it
from a city aquifer,
you notice the different
tastes in that.
And malt, depending on how
it's kilned or roasted,
can have every flavor from
Cheerios to Grape Nuts
to chocolate and
coffee and toffee
to even, like, burnt acrid.
You go to a good wood-fired
coal pizza place,
and the pie comes out.
And on the crust, you have that
little burnt bubble on the end.
And everybody reaches for
it instinctively, right?
And we know what it's
going to taste like.
It's carbon.
It's burnt.
But we do it anyway.
And we taste it, and it's
bitter on our tongue.
Malt can taste
like that as well.
There's people-- again, I use
Guinness as a great example
because it's a beer
that everybody's had
and everybody knows.
People swear that there's
coffee and chocolate in it.
There's absolutely not.
Those are two
expensive ingredients.
They're using malt that has
been roasted to taste like that.
And then hops can
tastes like everything
from grapefruit and pine
to pineapple and peach
and strawberry.
And there's blueberry
ones out there,
and there's tangerine and
lime and lemon and mango,
and everything else in between.
And then yeast can
have banana and bubble
gum and clove and
pepper and flowers
and honey and everything else.
So it all just depends
on the strains,
and how much you're using,
and what combination
you're using in them.
And then you can--
it's game on when it comes
to brewers these days,
where they're just putting--
anything goes in their beers
these days.
If you can eat it, brewers
have made a beer with it.
And everything is on the table.
Literally everything
is on the table.
From money to sheep shit to--
sorry, I don't know if
I can say that here.
I hope you guys are cool--
to all kinds of exotic fruits.
I had a beer that was once
brewed with grilled beef
hearts.
There was a beer
that Dogfish Head did
that was brewed with moon dust.
Everything is on the table.
And it's all ridiculous, but
it can also taste really good.
Sorry, this guy's got--
KEVIN NELSON: I saw
we had a hand up.
Can we--
JOHN HOLL: See, this is the
fun part about beer tastings,
right?
It's always like,
let's do it at the end.
And everybody's like, I've
had a couple of beers.
I got things to say.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
just about the saison.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
Aw, man.
AUDIENCE: What gives it more
of the characteristic flavor?
Is that the hops, or
the yeast, or the malt?
JOHN HOLL: More of the
yeast than anything else.
It's sort of a saison yeast
in the Belgian tradition.
But also the grain
bill helps a lot.
The hops are very not all that--
I'm not even speaking
intelligently anymore.
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: The chair .
JOHN HOLL: I know, I'm
going to fall asleep
in this comfortable chair.
Yeah, the hops play a
minimal, minimal role in this.
So it's usually just the
yeast strain and sort
of some of the malts
that go into it.
KEVIN NELSON: So,
perfect transition.
Hops kind of get
all the attention
in the beer world today.
JOHN HOLL: So much attention.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah.
But like as you're
talking about now,
malts and yeast really make
up that the dominant flavors.
JOHN HOLL: Well, I
don't know about that.
I think hops in IPAs
are the dominant flavor,
and that's the idea.
And these days with hazy,
juicy IPAs, where it's DDH,
it's Double Dry Hop, and
brewers are putting 20,
30 pounds of hops
into a barrel of beer,
which is a ridiculous waste
of ingredients, in my opinion.
But they're doing this anyway.
No, hops are definitely, in
IPAs, the dominant flavor.
But yeast is the most important.
Malt gives us the alcohol.
And then water is important.
But hops are sexy.
I mean, like, look at
this picture that's
up here right now.
That's a really cool-looking
piece of vegetation
that's growing.
And when you walk
the hop fields,
and you just see binds and binds
and binds of this as you go.
And it's vibrant, and it's
one of these things like where
the hop rubbings, when
you go to the farms
or you go to a brewery,
and you tear them open,
and there's the sticky
powder on the inside of--
lupulin.
It's an interactive
ingredient as well.
Malt, we sing about
it as kids when
we're singing amber waves of
grain in the national anthem--
not the national anthem.
In my country 'tis--
KEVIN NELSON: "America
the Beautiful."
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, "America
the Beautiful," thank you.
[CHUCKLES] Yeah.
I wish I could blame it on the
jet lag, but I really can't.
But yeah, you know,
so malt has always
been a part of our
collective experience.
But it's not sexy.
It's not marketable
in a lot of ways.
Malt goes into our cattle
feed, and our dog food,
and our Cheerios in the
morning kind of thing.
And it looks nice
when it's waving
in the breeze and everything.
But hops are really
unique to beer.
And so I think that that's
one of the other reasons
that it's become as--
I don't know, the front and
center, the mascot of beer,
than anything else.
KEVIN NELSON: So once we're
done here, over on the bar,
I brought in some various kinds
of malts that you can try.
You can actually pick up
some of that and chew it.
Taste-- each one
has its own flavor.
And two kinds of hops as well.
Don't eat those.
JOHN HOLL: Don't, don't, don't.
KEVIN NELSON: Just smell those.
JOHN HOLL: I got really nervous
that were going to-- like,
where are the interns?
It's like the interns
can go, and yeah.
That's what we used to do
at my old magazine with--
KEVIN NELSON: And then yeast.
I didn't bring any of yeast in,
but if you ever get a chance,
go down to White Labs
down in San Diego.
They do something
really interesting.
They take one wort,
which is the sugar
water you start with before
you ferment it into beer,
and they pitch four
different yeasts.
They split it into four
different fermenters
and pitch four different yeasts.
So then you taste the same beer.
And the only change in the
beer is from the yeast.
And it is fascinating.
Mind-blowing, if
you're a beer geek.
You go from nice,
traditional ales
to these cinnamon-y
clove Belgians
with just a change in the yeast.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
Yeast is all around us right
now, by the way, though.
If it got cold enough
and you guys brewed
a beer in your parking
lot or something,
and you wheeled it outside
into your parking lot
in the cold enough
weather, there's
natural yeast that
would inoculate.
KEVIN NELSON: And we see some
brewers doing this today.
They're doing some
wild yeast, definitely.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, that's like how
our nomadic ancestors did it.
KEVIN NELSON: So,
at that, I think
it's time for beer number two.
JOHN HOLL: Perfect.
KEVIN NELSON: What are we
going to be drinking here?
JOHN HOLL: I just
came from here.
Like, literally this is why
I was late getting here,
because I was drinking with Alex
Nowell, the brewmaster there,
who's a wonderful individual.
If you have a chance to go
down and visit their brewery,
it's like 20 minutes from here.
And this is their
Day Job Pale Ale.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, they're
just over in Inglewood.
It really is a great
spot to stop by.
You can bring food in, and
they're good folks over there.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
All right, so the thing
that I like about this beer
is I'm not against
the modern age hazy,
juicy IPAs that exist.
I'm not.
I think that they're
cool in a lot of ways,
and I love that it's
pushing the idea of beer
forward in America,
and what beer can be.
But I really like
looking at this beer.
This is a fun beer to look at.
And a lot of the hazy juicies
that are out there these days,
where they're thick
like milkshakes,
they're dense as all get
out, they're pulpy, juicy,
orange juicy things.
Garrett Oliver of
the Brooklyn Brewery
said not too long ago that
the hazy New England style
IPAs were the first beer
built for the Instagram age.
And it's true.
My Instagram is populated with
just endless, endless people
taking pictures of hazy,
juicy, light-consuming,
black star-esque IPAs.
But there's just
something about looking
at an almost-clear glass
of beer with a really nice,
fluffy white head.
KEVIN NELSON: And a nice logo.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah,
logos out always.
KEVIN NELSON: Thank you, Cleo.
JOHN HOLL: By all means.
Yeah, the New York
office is going
to be really jealous
of these, by the way.
KEVIN NELSON: They
always aren't.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN HOLL: Wow.
KEVIN NELSON: Cheers.
JOHN HOLL: Wow, all right.
It's the guy from Jersey.
I'm suddenly
feeling outnumbered.
But then, you know, it's got
this really nice tangerine note
to it.
A little bit of pine
on the background.
It's using some old school hops.
A little bit a new school
flavor to it as well.
And this just bridges the gap.
This is one of those
beers that, for me--
this is my day job, by the way.
Hanging out and drinking.
And this is the
beer that I would
want to just sort of
while away the afternoon.
As a complete aside,
and I don't know
if I get into this
in the book or not,
but I'm a huge advocate for
day drinking now and again.
KEVIN NELSON: Cheers.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
But seriously, just take
a day off and just go
sit in a bar with a book.
Not necessarily
this one, but just--
and this is the type
of beer where, I mean,
it's a lower ABV, right?
It's only in the
5% range I think.
Yeah 5.6%.
So you can have a
couple of these,
and it's not going
to put you under.
But just the lost
art of having a beer
during the middle of the day,
I think, is so important.
Or a drink during the
middle of the day.
And feeling a little
indulgent about it.
I think we've lost
our way a little bit
with, like, even technology
and some of these things
of always being connected.
It's just nice to
go sit in a bar.
And this is the type
of beer that would
lend itself perfectly to it.
KEVIN NELSON: It really is one
of my favorite things to do.
Sit at a bar, talk to people.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: It really
is a way to unplug
from all of our constant
notifications and stuff.
JOHN HOLL: Or just sit with
your own thoughts, you know?
On the podcast that I
do, Steal This Beer,
we're served beers blind.
So in black glasses,
the guest brings on--
it's this podcast that we do.
And the guest
brings on the beers.
We don't know what they are.
My co-host Augie Carton
from Carton brewing and I,
we don't know what they are.
They're served to
us in black glasses.
And we talk about what the
beer is, not necessarily
what we want it to be.
But then we also
write a sentence
of where we would like
to enjoy that beer.
And that's sort of a
fun exercise as well.
And this is, again,
the name plays to it.
But this is a beer
that I would just
go sit at the Venice Tap House.
Is that still open?
KEVIN NELSON: Yep,
Venice Ale House.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, the
last time I was here,
I got into a lot
of trouble there.
I almost missed a flight
on my way home from there.
Any of the guys who were
there, are you guys here?
Yeah.
That was fun.
That was so much fun.
I almost missed my flight.
It was pretty wild.
But yeah, yeah, well, we'll
try to repeat it, but yeah.
But think about those
types of things, like,
where you'd want to have a beer.
Try to place it situationally.
I don't know, I feel like I'm
off the rails at this point.
KEVIN NELSON: No, it's all good.
So you mentioned
earlier Prohibition
and the changes
that brought to you
beer drinking-- and any
alcoholic beverage drinking.
After the 21st Amendment,
things started to recover.
But things like farmers,
and there were just
all kinds of things that were
affected in the supply chain.
What's different about drinking
beer then versus drinking beer
today with these-- now we were
back up with more breweries,
finally, from pre-Prohibition.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
It's easier to drink better
beer than ever before.
And that's the thing.
It's also easier to drink
bad beer than ever before.
And it's true.
Just because you
can open a brewery
doesn't mean that you're
going to make great beer.
And so one of the
things, like I was
talking about with--
if you see carbonation
on the inside of
the glass, knowing
some of the off flavors
that exist in beer.
Like, if you taste
buttered popcorn,
or you taste wet
cardboard or smell
wet cardboard, or green apple.
A lot of these things that
we know in general life
are considered to be flaws
when it comes to beer.
You don't want to taste
buttered popcorn in your stout.
You don't want to
taste it in your lager.
You don't want to taste skunk
in your Dutch lager as well.
But we all know
that with Heineken,
and we kind of give
that a pass, right?
So, like, my dad
was drinking it.
But that happens because
the light comes in,
and the blue UV ray
negatively interacts
with the alpha acids
inside of hops and turns
hops to taste like skunk.
And it's something
that we all know.
But skunk in marijuana
sometimes is kind of desirable.
So it's these picking
and choosing things.
But when brewers are
putting stuff out,
and you taste these
things at a local brewery,
it doesn't necessarily mean
that they're making great beer.
And that's a larger
problem as well.
So with so much choice
come so much great,
because also you
can now taste beers
that are made with everything.
And brewers are
fearless, and they're
doing some really cool stuff.
But there's a lot of
good with a lot of bad.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah.
So, next topic, science.
This is something that
people don't normally
think of with beer.
JOHN HOLL: Is that Matt Farber?
From the University of
the Sciences in Philly?
KEVIN NELSON: That's
from the UC web
page for their brewing program.
JOHN HOLL: OK.
So that's UC Davis?
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah.
JOHN HOLL: That looks like
a guy who is also a brewing
professor in Philadelphia.
So they all look the
same, apparently.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN NELSON: Maybe only
when holding a glass.
JOHN HOLL: Professorial
white guy in glasses, yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: So how is science
used to make better beer?
You talk about people who open a
brewery and they make bad beer.
What goes on with it?
JOHN HOLL: They're
not embracing science.
That's the thing.
Science and technology are
at our fingertips right now.
I mean, we now
can know more than
at any other point
in our history.
And science and technology have
brought us closer as people.
I mean, it hasn't been
great in a lot of ways,
but it has made things
that we previously didn't
understand in the forefront.
KEVIN NELSON: No longer magic.
JOHN HOLL: Right.
It's no longer the
goddess of Ninkasi.
But I also don't think that
we should lose that as well.
I think we should
understand it and appreciate
that there are things
that happen in nature,
and that there is
nature, and that there
are these things
that will always
be a little bit outside of
our grasp of understanding.
And that's really cool
to sort of reach for it.
And we don't always have
to break it all down.
But you can run beer through
all manners of equipment
these days, and it'll tell you
exactly what's wrong with it.
And, like, that's cool.
We didn't have that 15
years ago, 30 years ago.
Our grandparents didn't have it.
And so I think it's pushing
us forward ever more.
And I love the role
that it's playing
in that aspect of
the beer industry.
KEVIN NELSON: Nice.
You talked earlier about
all the different kinds
of ingredients that are
going into beer these days.
JOHN HOLL: Yep.
KEVIN NELSON: We're in--
we're in the fall
season now where
there's pumpkin spice
lattes and pumpkin breads
and everything else.
You can't swing a dead
cow without hitting
something pumpkin.
JOHN HOLL: You're setting
me up here, uh-huh.
You got to get interesting
story about the origin
of these pumpkin these pumpkin
flavored beverages Yeah,
and now I can't remember it.
[LAUGHTER]
So everybody thinks
of PSL when it comes
to Starbucks and everything.
And good on them.
Beer did it first.
It's the old "South
Park" episode.
Simpsons did it.
Yeah, it's-- boy, I just
dated myself there, didn't I?
That was, like, even less of
the crowd knowing about 45 rpm.
Yeah, so beer was doing
pumpkin-flavored beers
early on.
I don't care for them.
I'm of the camp that
they should all just
be rounded up, put in a
giant pile, and set on fire.
But I also know that
there's people who love it.
And it goes back to the
saison thing before.
I don't like that combination
of spices in real life,
not necessarily in beer life.
I don't like it.
I don't pumpkin
pie, but people do.
But the cool thing is, is
that beer is a blank canvas.
And so there's a
brewery in Wisconsin
that I wrote about a couple
of weeks ago for "Craft Beer
& Brewing" magazine,
where I work,
that did a candy corn beer.
And they sort of
mimicked candy corn.
And then I just saw on
the news this morning
that now they're doing
a white stout that
evokes the idea of eggnog.
And there are beers that
tastes like s'mores,
and there are beers that
taste like bear claws,
or Bavarian donuts--
Boston cream donuts, I
should say-- or jelly donuts,
or whatever.
Beer is a blank canvas,
in a lot of ways,
to add flavors to things.
And that, I think,
is kind of cool,
because I don't
begrudge people who
like whatever it is that's in
that glass up on the screen
right there.
But I don't want to drink it.
KEVIN NELSON: So I think it's
time for beer number three.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: What are
we going to have here?
JOHN HOLL: Excellent question.
So now we're getting
into the next--
so we went from a pale ale, and
now we're going into an IPA.
This is a brewery that
I haven't been to yet
but I know is
really popular when
it comes to this general area.
And in fact, my Uber
driver on the way over here
asked if I had been
to El Segungo yet.
Segundo?
KEVIN NELSON: El Segundo.
JOHN HOLL: Segundo.
I'm going to butcher it.
And I said, no, I
haven't been yet.
And he's like, oh, they
did a Steve Austin beer.
And I was like, that's cool.
Did you go to the brewery
because of Steve Austin?
And he's like, yeah,
yeah, that's why I went.
And I was like,
that's really cool.
So it's a cool
local brewery that's
doing some really cool stuff.
Whoop.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, they're
good, good folks over there.
You should definitely
go check it out.
They're, of course-- they're
mainly known for IPAs.
They do many, many
varieties of IPAs.
Lots of different hop
varieties, so it's fun.
You can really taste the
individual types of hops
in their beers.
JOHN HOLL: But even the
clarity off of this-- and I
can taste a little
bit more of the sugar.
So this is obviously
a thicker beer.
If you do mouth
feel, the hold it
on your tongue for
three seconds again,
you're definitely
going to come across
where it's going to coat
your tongue a little bit.
It's going to be a
little bit more viscous.
It's going to be a little
bit more tongue coating.
This is really fun.
It's got that sweetness to it.
It's got a little bit of pine.
It's dank in some ways, to
use that current phrase,
as it were.
KEVIN NELSON: Herbaceous?
JOHN HOLL: Herbaceous, yeah.
It's kind to
everybody, as it were.
If this actually goes up
online, my wife will watch this.
And she'll be like, you tried
to make a marijuana reference.
That was really cute.
You don't know shit.
And neither does she, but
she knows more than I do.
She's going to be
like, oh, you tried.
That was really cute.
Yeah, this is just a fun beer.
It's an easy drinking beer.
This is probably
higher in ABV, right?
KEVIN NELSON: I'm
guessing about seven.
JOHN HOLL: It is.
It's straight up 7%.
This, at some point, will go in
the Museum of Beer Technology
of a 22-ounce bottle.
Everybody is doing
cans these days.
Everybody is switching to cans.
The 22-ounce bomber
bottle that you either
could drink by yourself if
you are having a tough day,
or that you could share
it with your friends
if you are feeling generous.
This is a packaging style
that probably will not
exist in widespread use in
another year and a half.
So this is kind of fun.
We're ahead of the curve.
We're watching the
dinosaur watch the--
AUDIENCE: Why the can movement?
JOHN HOLL: What's that?
JOHN HOLL: Oh, why
the can movement?
A couple of different--
I'll jump over
there in a second.
The question was, why
they can movement.
Most breweries are switching
to cans these days.
One-- I love this.
One, it keeps out all light.
So you're not going to get that
Heineken problem, especially
with so many hoppy beers
being made these days.
When you put a beer
in brown glass,
it doesn't let light through
as much as green glass.
So this is why most craft
brewers use brown glass.
Clear glass is
absolutely the worst
because it lets the most
amount of light through,
so your beer will
skunk really fast.
Green it'll skunk
less fast, but still.
And brown, it'll take
just a little bit longer.
Cans let no light through.
That's first and foremost.
It's also lighter packaging.
They're easier to transport.
They're easier to pack.
They're easier to stack.
For outdoor lifestyles,
which craft beer has really
sort of embraced, of hiking
and biking and fishing
and everything, it's easier
to carry around cans in,
and it's also easier-- much
easier-- to carry them out,
recycling-wise.
So there's a lot
of benefits to it.
KEVIN NELSON: So, speaking
of glass for bottles,
you made quite a strong
point in the book
about not liking
what we kind of think
of as the traditional
draft beer glass.
JOHN HOLL: Hate it.
KEVIN NELSON: Why is that?
JOHN HOLL: It does no
favors to the beer.
It does zero favors to the beer.
So there's white wine
glasses and red wine glasses,
and there's science
behind why they work.
Wine figured out marketing early
on in the US post prohibition.
And they got themselves in
the white linen tablecloth
restaurants, and
they said, if you're
going to go out and
spend $50 on a bottle,
it might as well be wine.
And we didn't have beer
that was worth $50 like when
all this was happening.
Now we do.
Now we have beers that are
worth $300, or $400 or $500,
as it were.
There's wine prices in beer now.
So we had this utilitarian,
one-size-fits-all glass that
if you didn't want beer, but
you also wanted soda or seltzer
or apple juice on the
rocks or whatever,
this was the easily
stackable beer glass.
Utilitarian, all-purpose
glass, as it were.
I'm trying to think of a
technology thing, but I can't.
But I think that when you have
even a glass like this that
has a wider lip
at the top of it,
you can get your nose in if you
do want to smell it that way.
You're not going
to dribble down.
There's ergonomics
that go into glassware.
And the pint glass just
is not where it should be.
KEVIN NELSON: Yeah, a lot of
well-known European beers, they
have a traditional glass
associated with that.
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
KEVIN NELSON: And if
you go to a bar there,
you'll typically-- you'll
get that glass for that beer.
JOHN HOLL: Sure.
So Duvel or Orval,
or some of these
have their own
branded glassware.
Those aren't necessarily
built for making the beer
taste better as much
as it is marketing.
The Orval glass looks
like the Orval glass,
and you should only
drink Orval in it.
And I think that that's
correct because that's the way
that they want you to do it.
And there's people
who will disagree
and say, well, you can
drink it in anything.
And yeah, of course.
You can drink it in a
jelly jar if you want to.
But I think it adds to
an overall experience.
I don't think that
the pint glass
adds to the overall
beer-drinking experience.
If you're out at
a bar and somebody
serves it to you, cool.
But if you're at home, invest in
a really nice beer glass or two
in the same way that
you might a wine glass,
and it'll make it better.
KEVIN NELSON: There a
question over there?
AUDIENCE: Do you
know the beer glass
that the Sam Adams
brewery tour gives out?
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And they really make
a huge point of talking it up
and all its different features.
Is that actually
a good beer glass?
JOHN HOLL: It is.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have several at home.
That's why I'm asking.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, they
call it the perfect pint.
Sam Adams spent, I don't know, a
couple hundred thousand dollars
researching that.
It has nucleation points
on the bottom of the glass,
so all of the carbonation
is concentrated
and then rises to the
top and sort of keeps
this nice head of foam going.
It's got a wide lip
on there as well,
so you can get your lip
around it and your nose
in without spill-- like, they
spent some fun time on it.
The problem is, it's
really great for home.
It's impractical,
even at Applebee's,
because the other breweries
don't want their beer being
served out of a Sam Adams
glass because that's
marketing for them.
The glass doesn't
necessarily stack well--
maybe two or three-- before
it becomes like a Jenga
game that's unwieldy.
Where the shaker pint, like,
you can walk into places
and it's 20, 30 deep against
the wall, as it were.
So this is the cockroach
of beer glasses.
It's not going to go away.
But that doesn't
mean that at home you
can't have great beer glasses.
There's a guy in
Knoxville, Tennessee.
The Pretentious Beer Glass
Company, he calls himself.
And it's all tongue-in-cheek.
But he has an MFA
in glass blowing.
And he makes beer glasses.
And it's what I use at home
when I'm feeling extra fancy.
And I love it.
But for the most
part, I just drink out
of a tulip glass at home
just because I like the stem.
I like the aroma.
I like how it feels in my hand.
It's kind of fun.
KEVIN NELSON: Nice.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: You talked
about bottles already,
but I wanted to read a quote
from a friend of yours, Nate
Schweber, you have in the book.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: This is a
poetry about beer bottles.
"As sleek as airplane wings
and smooth as polished stone,
these laborers of
the beer industry
sweat like construction
workers, sing
like wind chimes when clinked,
and sigh like happy man
when relieved of pressure."
Can you say anything more?
We already talked about
color and stuff, but--
JOHN HOLL: No, no, I can't.
And that's why I quoted Nate
in the book saying that.
So Nate Schweber, who works
for the "New York Times,"
who's one of my
closest friends, who
wrote a great book
on fly fishing
about Yellowstone, if
anybody likes to fly fish,
go pick up Nate's book.
Shameless plug for that.
But no, it's poetic.
And beer is poetic.
Like, there's so
many things where
I think if we just show up at
the bar at the end of the day,
and we say, beer, and, you
know, we do this type of thing.
But I think if we stop to
think about the artistry that
goes into it, or even just
the ergonomics of a bottle,
or the ergonomics of a glass,
or how a glass feels in our hand
this way versus
another one, there's
a lot of romance in drinking.
There's a lot of
romance in beer,
a lot of romance
in the ingredients
and the passion that
goes in behind it.
And I love that quote from Nate.
I think it's some of the
most beautiful writing that's
been done on beer ever.
And I've read a lot on it.
And I was the editor at
"All About Beer" magazine
when we published those words.
And as soon as I read
it, I was like, damn it,
I'm putting this on the cover.
It's brilliant.
So yeah, I think we have
to think about it that way.
KEVIN NELSON: Very nice.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
KEVIN NELSON: So, anybody
want to have another beer?
OK.
What are we drinking here?
JOHN HOLL: Brother Thelonious.
So, this is from North Coast.
KEVIN NELSON: Where are they?
JOHN HOLL: They are in
Northern California.
They're north from here.
KEVIN NELSON: Look at
that beautiful color.
Cheers.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
[CHUCKLING] Yeah, sure.
All right.
I love this beer.
So this is an abbey ale
from North Coast that part
of the proceeds--
I actually don't know where
they're at these days.
But part of the proceeds went
towards the Thelonious Monk
Jazz Institute for scholarships
and things like that.
I don't know what
it is on the bottle,
but this is at
least 12%, 13%, 14%.
AUDIENCE: 9.4%.
JOHN HOLL: 9.4%?
All right, well, I was way off.
This is one of those
beers that when I saw it
on the distributor list,
I got really excited,
because I don't get this a
lot where I live anymore.
And it's just such a really
nice, fun, indulgent beer,
in a way.
The last time that I saw this on
tap at my local back in Jersey
City, New Jersey, I had a pint
of it, because I was like, oh,
it'd be irresponsible
if I didn't.
And then it was irresponsible
that I had two more afterwards.
And I think I called out
of work the next day.
KEVIN NELSON: Cheers.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, I know, it's--
the small pour goes a long way.
But this is-- you get that sort
of roasted brown sugar, candy
sugar thing going on with it.
It's got some dark stone fruit,
like a little bit of plum
and fig coming through as well.
We started off with the
Allagash Saison, which
is an American interpretation
of what a Saison should be,
but that tries to stay
as true to the style.
And ending on this
beer is very much
the same way, that in
between the two IPAs
are very much these
beers that have
defined the American tradition
and the American beer market.
But right now, the
two beers that sort of
bookended this show us the old
world of where we came from.
And I think that that's
really important.
As all things progress, we
can't forget our history.
We can't forget where
things came from.
And in technology, right?
It's like, I think about
my first Nokia phone
back in the day.
The 5150.
And I appreciate now
that I have a Samsung 9
or whatever in my pocket.
But, like, it's--
KEVIN NELSON: Android.
JOHN HOLL: Yeah, yeah, it's
definitely-- yeah, it's--
yeah.
Yes, very much so.
Android here.
I'm going to stop
at the Help desk,
if that's cool, on the way out.
No, but like, to remember
where we came from, I think,
is really important to
appreciate where we are today.
KEVIN NELSON: So
I had a question
I was going to ask you
about how do all these--
JOHN HOLL: That's
just a mean sign.
KEVIN NELSON: --about how do
all the breweries stand out
in this cacophony
of brewery today?
But we're almost out of time.
So if we can, I'm going to
go ahead and skip this one.
JOHN HOLL: All right.
KEVIN NELSON: And I'd like
you to end on talking about
something-- a topic that's
been in the news a lot today,
even here at Google--
sexism in beer.
One of our beers today
from Three Weavers
is a female-owned brewery.
It's three women who own that.
JOHN HOLL: Yep.
KEVIN NELSON: Maybe
talk just a bit
about kind of the
history of sexism
in beer, and where
the industry is today.
JOHN HOLL: It's getting better.
It's getting better.
For a long time, it was a
male-dominated industry,
both in the people who
worked at the brewery
and who owned the brewery.
But beer itself as a
beverage doesn't know gender.
It doesn't know sex.
It doesn't know religion.
It doesn't know creed.
It doesn't know your
political beliefs, as it were.
It's a great leveler
in a lot of ways.
But when the beer
that was being made
for a long time of the
beer-flavored beer,
the American industrial
light lager, yeah,
there's women who
drank it, but it
wasn't being marketed to them.
In fact, it was almost
being marketed against them,
where you'd see Budweiser
commercials with women
in bikinis being
objectified, and then
the guys clinking their
glasses, being like, yeah.
And these days, you walk into a
tap room like at Three Weavers,
and it's diverse.
People are coming
for the good beer.
And they can come
from the tech sector,
or they can drive an Uber,
or they can be a reporter,
or they can be whatever.
And they're all coming
in for the same beer.
And it's sort of this
great leveler for us.
And so yeah, sexism still
exists in the industry.
And I get into it
in the book where
there's some breweries
that have done
some really boneheaded things,
some really stupid things.
Naming their beers that
seemingly promote rape culture,
or that are xenophobic,
or homophobic,
or anything else in between.
And if you're doing that
and you're a brewer,
get the hell out
of the industry.
Just, like, stop.
We don't need it.
We don't want it.
But I think that consumers
are speaking up now more
and more thanks to technology.
And there's a lot of
cool things that exist
between beer and technology.
But if somebody posts something
on Facebook, and they're like,
hey, we've named this beer, and
it's this really idiotic name,
it whips around the world
so fast with smart people
being like, knock this off.
Like, this is wrong.
And you can almost
set an egg timer
to when the apology
is going to happen.
And I think that that's
great, because it keeps people
in check, and it
sort of hopefully
drives that culture underground
enough so that it eventually
just disappears.
Because we don't
need it in our world.
KEVIN NELSON: I have
some more questions,
but we're really out of time.
JOHN HOLL: OK.
KEVIN NELSON: Check
out John's podcast,
where he discusses this and
other interesting topics
in the beer world.
So check it out.
John, thanks so much for coming.
JOHN HOLL: Thanks so much.
This was a real pleasure.
KEVIN NELSON: Real pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]